RETO MEIER: Today we find
out how it feels to be
the eye in the sky.
IAN NI-LEWIS: We learn
to stop worrying and
love the Weather Bomb.
RETO MEIER: And we find out why
this week, neither one of
us are wearing pants.
All in the next half hour on--
BOTH: The App Clinic.
RETO MEIER: Today we're looking
at weather apps
Weather Bomb, Eye in the Sky,
and Should I Wear Pants?
IAN NI-LEWIS: And then we're
going to dig a little deeper
into how Weather Bomb renders
its awesome map.
RETO MEIER: So let's
have a look at
weather apps in general.
What are the things it
really needs in order
to be a good app?
IAN NI-LEWIS: Well obviously,
it needs to tell me today's
weather, right?
RETO MEIER: That seems like
a pretty good start.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Because obviously,
I don't want to get
out of bed or open the window.
RETO MEIER: Precisely.
That would be too much
to ask, right?
IAN NI-LEWIS: Absolutely.
RETO MEIER: You want to be able
to know this stuff before
you get out of bed.
It would also be nice to know
tomorrow's weather.
IAN NI-LEWIS: And the seven
day forecast, I
would go for that.
RETO MEIER: Exactly.
All the things which mean that
you no longer are a slave to
the 11 o'clock news.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Absolutely.
RETO MEIER: You also want
to have results that are
localized, right?
Something which knows where
you are to give you the
weather forecast for the city
that you're in, rather than
the general state.
IAN NI-LEWIS: That's true, but
I don't necessarily want it
too local, because really, what
I want to know is how
cold or windy is it going to
be at the beach this time.
RETO MEIER: That's true.
Which means you really
want to be able to
have multiple locations.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Can you tell we're
in northern California?
Because I didn't say how hot
and sunny is it going
to be at the beach.
RETO MEIER: Yeah.
And that's the thing where we
are here in sunny sometimes
northern California, it's an
area of extreme microclimates.
So localization of the weather
is really important, and the
ability to know which direction
you need to drive
for it to get less foggy is
kind of a killer feature.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Exactly.
RETO MEIER: We're going to take
things up a little further.
What we really like to see is a
lot of the stuff that you're
used to seeing at the
11 o'clock news.
Things like rich maps with sort
of more meteorological
information, like topography
charts, satellites, those
sorts of things.
IAN NI-LEWIS: And also I want to
see maps when I'm choosing
my location.
RETO MEIER: Yeah, absolutely.
That way you don't have to know
what city the beach is
in, you just point at
the each, job done.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Oh, yeah.
Anytime I can get away from
putting in text to my mobile
phone, excellent.
But I don't just want that,
because I'm super lazy, I also
want widgets.
I want to be able to see the
weather immediately when I
unlock my phone.
RETO MEIER: In fact, I want to
go a step further and say,
maybe there's a case here for
some rich notifications,
something which has a little sun
or cloud or whatever else,
and there's a really good
example of where you might
want to use a low priority
notification.
So it doesn't pop up, it doesn't
ping me, but when I
pull down the slide, I've got
that extra information hand.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Although I didn't
mind knowing what the
temperature is at all times
in my notification bar.
I thought that was kind
of a cool feature.
But of course, none of this is
going to be any good if your
battery runs down all the time,
and so we're going to go
ahead and beat this dead
horse one more time--
all of these things depend on
efficient background updates
that are done in a way that
won't drain your battery.
RETO MEIER: This is actually
another really good tip here,
is that if you do want to do
your updates, say that you
know that the new weather
forecast comes in once a day,
so you want to wake up the phone
at 2:00 AM every morning
to get that new fresh weather
forecast each day, make sure
that you're not doing that
at an exact time.
Because what you'll find is that
if everyone else is doing
the right thing and saying, look
we're not going to start
anything unless someone turns
on the phone to do this
update, you know you have to do
it then, suddenly you turn
on not just one user's device,
but everyone who has your app
installed at the same time, and
then floods the bandwidth
with everyone else's
updates as well.
So you want to make sure you're
making that this fuzzy
is possible.
2:00 AM-ish, plus or minus an
hour, so that you give your
servers a chance to not get
flooded, as well as the mobile
phone operator's bandwidth.
IAN NI-LEWIS: If only there
were an API that
would do that for me.
RETO MEIER: Indeed.
Something like an inexact
repeating alarm, perhaps.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Really?
I'll have to keep
that in mind.
So let's go ahead and take
a look at our apps.
RETO MEIER: Indeed.
So you can see the icons
at the bottom.
We are going to start
with Weather Bomb.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Bomb-diddy-bomb-
di-bomb-bomb-diddy--
OK, sorry.
RETO MEIER: So you can see here,
the feature page here,
it is a riot of color.
Which is aptly depicted in their
app icon, which is in
fact a four color logo of
raindrops, I suppose.
Slightly concerning, the concept
of there being four
colored raindrops.
But nonetheless, it is
consistent with their overall
UI or branding, I suppose, which
I guess is multi-color.
I guess that's kind of their
killer feature, is the fact
that they've got these multiple
overlays over the top
of their map views, which show
all these rich colors.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Yeah,
absolutely.
RETO MEIER: That said, the
actual feature graphic itself,
again, is falling into that trap
of looking a little bit
amateurish.
This is not an amateur app.
This has been really well put
together, but look here and it
just feels a little bit
like the bits are
pulled together, and--
IAN NI-LEWIS: Yeah, it hasn't
gotten within a few miles of a
professional graphic
artist, I think.
At least not the layout--
each little bit looks
really nice.
RETO MEIER: Exactly.
So it's the composition here
that I think could
use a lot of work.
You want to avoid things like
italicized serifed fonts
within the feature graphic.
Because again, as things get
smaller and smaller, they're
going to be harder to read.
In fact, even from just a few
feet away, I'm getting the
impression that I may need to
either clean my glasses, or
update my prescription, because
I can barely read
insightful weather there.
IAN NI-LEWIS: This is something
that a lot of people
get wrong, and don't even
realize until you see it on a
small device.
If your logo, the app name and
your logo is not at least
twice as big as Weather Bomb
has, you're not going to be
visible on a lot of devices, and
you're not going to sell.
RETO MEIER: Exactly.
And you want to avoid
duplicating things.
There's always a question of
whether you put the apps title
and catch line in the
feature graphic.
There is certainly an argument
for that, but in this case,
it's not really adding anything
to the aesthetic.
Similarly, you want to put the
app icon into feature graphic.
You've already got the
multicolored raindrops, which
is that branding effect, but
you want to avoid actually
duplicating content.
Because as you can see here,
you're just sort of seeing the
same thing repeated over and
over again It just feels like
things were cut and pasted.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Also, I wouldn't
mind a slightly different
treatment on the icon itself.
RETO MEIER: The rounded
corners.
IAN NI-LEWIS: It looks
a little familiar.
Not just the rounded corners
but that little swatch of
color, like a reflection
across the top.
RETO MEIER: That's
a good point.
IAN NI-LEWIS: I've seen
that before and
it wasn't on Android.
RETO MEIER: It's an interesting
opportunity here,
because again, what we're
looking for is a unique
silhouette, something
which really stands
out and looks great.
So some sort of treatment here
that just removes the box as a
first step, and just has the
four raindrops would be an
interesting place to start.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Absolutely.
RETO MEIER: So let's move on.
Let's have a look at
the app itself.
So we're going to bring
up the giant phone.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Giant phone?
Giant phone?
There we go.
All right, let's pull
the app up.
There's a EULA at the
beginning, which is
unsurprising.
And then there is a page of text
which took me quite some
time to get past it
and understand.
Not just to read it, but to
actually figure out how to
dismiss it.
RETO MEIER: It's like you're
looking here, and it's like,
OK, so this is the wizard,
where's the OK button?
How do I--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
IAN NI-LEWIS: We're going to do
a huge favor for all of our
viewers and show you how to get
to the second page of this
Weather Bomb app.
And that is hit the refresh
button which shouldn't be
there anyway,
RETO MEIER: It's an interesting
implementation here.
They actually had a countdown
built into the refresh button,
which is interesting.
But really, we're trying to get
to a point now, with app
design, where we can sort of
banish the refresh button.
A lot of users are still going
to want it there, particularly
for things like weather or
email, where they're like,
seriously, I want to have
up to the second.
But that's a good thing to put
in something like an overflow
menu, so that it is there for
people who want it, but
ideally, no one does.
Everything just refreshes and
does everything for you.
In an app like this, there is
that EULA at the beginning,
which is going to take some time
to someone at least look
at and dismiss if not
read through.
That's a great time to
do that pre-cacheing.
It only took a few seconds
to bring that first page
information.
When someone downloads and opens
your app for the first
time, they hit the icon, bypass
the EULA, and this is
the first thing that they see,
this is pretty compelling.
IAN NI-LEWIS: It really is.
RETO MEIER: Compared to a page
full of text with a big bright
red on black text right
at the start.
It's something you want to get
to awesomeness of your app as
quickly as possible.
And this looks awesome.
The previous page looked, again,
a little amateurish.
IAN NI-LEWIS: I don't know if
the author of this app is
running analytics, but it would
be fascinating to see
just how much abandonment
there is--
RETO MEIER: Yeah, what
is the drop of?
IAN NI-LEWIS: I know I probably
wouldn't have gone
through with it if it wasn't
my job to do so.
Which is not a ringing
endorsement.
The app itself did reward my
patience richly though.
RETO MEIER: Yeah, and this
looks really nice.
We were talking about
the nice to have.
I mean they've got a map here
at the start, and it seems
that if I drag left to right,
it's going to go through the
time and show this real time
map of satellite--
I guess it's rainfall
coverage.
That would make more sense.
IAN NI-LEWIS: I think you can
actually pick some different--
RETO MEIER: Oh, nice.
IAN NI-LEWIS: There was
rain, we've got wind--
which is always nice to
know in this area.
RETO MEIER: A little
surprising.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
Now, the only thing that bugged
me about this map,
actually, was that I had to
pinch to zoom on a reasonably
small area.
In this case, where I know
exactly where I want to zoom
to, I really prefer the double
tap to zoom, and it doesn't
support that.
I wasn't sure why.
RETO MEIER: I wonder if this
is the Android map library
that they've used here, or if
they've got something custom
that they've built themselves.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Actually, we'll
see later that it is not the
Android map library.
RETO MEIER: You've done
some investigation.
Excellent.
Well, we'll look into that.
But certainly the
functionality here is fantastic.
It is a very busy screen,
which is worth noting.
And in fact, the killer feature
here is really this
map, which is front
and center.
But once you have the notes on
the bottom and the various
stuff on top, we've got
a lot of content.
IAN NI-LEWIS: I think you
can dismiss the note.
But yeah, I agree completely
that you've got some real
problems crowding the screen.
And some of these things are
sort of nice to have.
Like maybe you really do want us
to have the graph, but the
graph up here is really
redundant with the time map.
So it seems like you could
have one or the other
RETO MEIER: Exactly.
Or at least--
IAN NI-LEWIS: Just give you an
option to view it or not.
RETO MEIER: Exactly.
Some way to swipe to dismiss,
or to collapse, or something
like that, so that you can
really enjoy this really
engaging interaction model.
IAN NI-LEWIS: I was happy that
it's very easy to drop down
and pick locations, but it's
relatively difficult to add
new locations.
I was really hoping that I could
just do something with
this map to add a location
instead.
It was a little harder.
I've got to go to this other
page, then I've got to hit
plus, and then I've got
to do a lat long.
Now I think if I--
no, I don't know how
to get to a map.
RETO MEIER: I don't
think you can.
I think you can search
for places, but you
can pick off a map.
And that would be a really
interesting view to just allow
you to just go straight
off the map.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Any time you have
a lat long, you should be
able to do a map.
It it's like having a date,
you want to also have a
calendar picker, I think.
RETO MEIER: So this is
interesting as well.
You'll note that every time--
now that we've added a new
location we get that same
start up screen again.
So again, really here, we
don't need the extra
instruction, you should really
be a initiating that sync as
soon as I add the new place in
the expectation that I'm going
to switch to it at some point.
Otherwise, it's a really
nicely polished app.
Again, you may be underplaying
some of the data.
It's really a question here of
what do you want to emphasize?
What is the main thing
you want users to
take away from here?
Because we have the temperature,
but it's in a
light gray, and it's absolutely
tiny at the top
left here, which is arguably
one of the more important
things you're going to want
to share with users.
So again, just take that
into consideration.
What are people going to want?
What are they going
to want to do?
And make it as easy
as possible.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Now of course,
Weather Bomb is still in beta,
and the author has mentioned
that he's got a lot of plans
to add certain things.
So I think that--
why don't we just ignore some
of the basic layout issues,
and focus on the fact that the
map is a really cool feature.
RETO MEIER: Definitely.
IAN NI-LEWIS: We're going to
talk about it a little bit
later, cover it in
more detail.
For now, why don't we go ahead
and move on to Eye in the Sky?
RETO MEIER: OK, let's do that.
So yeah, nicely done.
Great to hear that
it's in beta.
Definitely a promising app.
Let's have a look at
Eye in the Sky.
So this is Eye In Sky
feature page.
This is actually quite good.
IAN NI-LEWIS: It's not bad.
RETO MEIER: It's got a
distinctive logo, it's kind of
an eye-type look.
It would be kind of creepy if it
was a real eye, so I think
I like the fact that
it's stylized.
And it's in the sky!
Which is nice.
IAN NI-LEWIS: There you go.
RETO MEIER: Almost want to
question whether you want to
call it Eye In Sky or
Eye in the Sky.
IAN NI-LEWIS: I've been
calling it Eye in
the Sky all day long.
RETO MEIER: As have I, which
seems like a small thing--
IAN NI-LEWIS: And I've been
singing that Alan Parsons
Project song, which nobody
but me remembers.
RETO MEIER: That's because
you are old.
Old, old, old.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Apparently so.
RETO MEIER: So the danger in
having a name which is similar
to something which people are
familiar with, but actually
not the same, is that people are
going to search for using
the name that they
think it is.
So a lot of people are going to
be like, oh Eye in the Sky,
great, search for it, and that
may not be the top result.
It may be confused with
something else.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
IAN NI-LEWIS: --become very
popular, then your results
will bubble up, and all of a
sudden people searching for
Eye in the Sky will get
to your app instead.
But that actually takes quite
a long time and a lot of
popularity.
So I wouldn't count on it.
RETO MEIER: Yeah, so you want
to make sure that people are
going to get what they're
looking for.
And I can see that you've
actually changed the name to
Eye In Sky Weather, which again,
is going to be helpful
for people searching
for weather.
You want to be careful with
over-optimizing your titles
and those sorts of things, but
at the very least, you want to
make sure that you can take
advantage of that word of
mouth type discovery.
IAN NI-LEWIS: By the way, real
quick point on the search
algorithm, a lot of people
complain during the first
three or four days their app
is available that typing in
the app's exact name won't
actually bring that app into
the first search results,
sometimes not
even in the top ten.
And this is exactly why, because
we do try to alter the
user's search phrase, or search
on phrases that have
resulted in successful
searches in the past.
So there's a really, really
fancy algorithm going on,
based on what we think is going
to please the user the
most, and it takes a little
while to adjust.
RETO MEIER: So I think the last
comment we want to make
here again, and you'll see a
lot of these sort of the
themes recurring as we go
through a lot of these apps,
but again, we've kind of got
this squared off square icon.
Which all it does is bound this
really distinctive and
interesting silhouette.
So again, I think you can get
a lot further in terms of
creating that really great app
icon by just removing that
background.
So let's switch to the giant
phone and I have a look at Eye
In the-- see, I've even written
Eye in the Sky.
I apologize for mislabeling
here.
Again, we've got the
release notes.
Now this is kind of a
pet peeve of mine.
I don't want to have to dismiss
things, particularly
because it's release notes here,
strongly suggested if I
get an update at some point
after I've got this installed,
this is going to come
up again and again.
For most users, you can display
this information on
Google Play, otherwise
users don't care.
They assume that you're
going to fix bugs and
those sorts of things.
If they're really interested to
see the specific bug that's
been fixed, they can do that
on the Google Play listing.
Within the app itself, you want
to make sure they can get
from hitting the button to
using the app with as few
steps as possible.
IAN NI-LEWIS: See, I'm not
with you on that, Reto.
I actually have a different
opinion.
One of my favorite apps, gReader
pro, updates maybe
once a month, and I really enjoy
having their release
notes pop up.
I have my Google Play set to
auto update, so I never
realize when something's
getting updated.
Of course I don't want to be
bothered for minor bug fixes,
but a lot of times they'll put
in a really cool new feature,
and I wouldn't know whether
to try that feature.
I wouldn't know how to try
to that feature if they
[INAUDIBLE].
RETO MEIER: Perhas that's the
key, is that compromise of
making sure that you only
display it if there are
significant fixes or significant
new features that
people may want to take
advantage of.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Exactly.
And certainly displaying it the
first time you launch the
app seems a little odd.
Lazy, maybe.
RETO MEIER: You've had to
install it at some point from
somewhere, so likely it
is you know what the
app currently does.
App itself looks really nice.
I really quite like the
minimalist approach here.
They've got a nice view pager
implementation for being able
to switch between the current
temperature, 48 hour detailed
view, and long range forecast,
which is nice.
Again, you can have multiple
locations.
Again here, there's no obvious
way to add locations.
I'm looking for a plus
button here.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
IAN NI-LEWIS: Or you know what
I would also accept is a
magnifying glass here.
Because that tells me whatever
is in the area up here at the
top of the screen is
probably what that
search is going to do.
RETO MEIER: That makes
a lot of sense.
IAN NI-LEWIS: I think this
places icon will
actually take you--
RETO MEIER: It does the same
thing, and it takes us to
basically what we
were expecting.
So the ability to add manually,
or-- and I'm
guessing this is going to
take you to your map.
Now we don't have the correct
version of Google Play
services installed here, because
it's a specially Flash
device, but nonetheless, it will
take you to the map and
give you exactly what
you were hoping for.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Yeah, so, a few
more button presses than I
would have hoped, and also a
little bit more tricky than I
would have hoped.
I saw that plus button and
instinctively pressed it, and
then was disappointed that
there was no map.
But then I saw the map button,
and oh, that's how you do it
RETO MEIER: Exactly.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Could be a
little more intuitive.
RETO MEIER: Otherwise, it's
really nice and simple.
I think that's the main
takeaway here.
It's immediately obvious, all
of the key information is
right there on the page when
you first start up the app,
and everything else is
just a swipe away.
There's no refresh on the main
screen, but it is hidden away
here in the overflow menu if you
desperately want to know
whether the weather has changed
significantly in the
last 30 seconds.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Now one of things
that this app really
wins at is widgets.
They have several different
widgets.
RETO MEIER: Nice.
IAN NI-LEWIS: And I really
enjoyed their
widget setup process.
I have a couple beefs with it,
but in general, I think that
they've provided the widgets
that I wanted--
let's just scroll
over to that.
RETO MEIER: They've
got the preview.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Ah, yes.
And when I place it, I get
this widget configuration
which shows me the widget
against my wallpaper, so
exactly how it's going
to appear.
And that's great, because on my
personal phone, I've got a
photo of my family, and it can
be really difficult to get a
wallpaper that looks good
and widgets that
look good with that.
Now one thing I love about this
is that I can set the
transparency on the widget.
And then see a preview of it.
RETO MEIER: That's very tidy.
IAN NI-LEWIS: And my only
quibble is I would love for
that to not be a dialogue so
that I could see the preview
at the same time that I'm
picking the transparency,
instead of right after.
Minor point, it would make
a big difference.
RETO MEIER: It's a quibble, but
it would definitely make a
big difference.
That's a really nice feature.
IAN NI-LEWIS: And one more,
except I don't know how to get
back to their widget
configuration.
RETO MEIER: It's generally
not an easy thing to do.
I think you'll find
you probably have
to add a new one.
[INAUDIBLE] per widget.
IAN NI-LEWIS: I will simply
mention that they also have I
think nine or 10 different skins
that you can put on the
widget, going from their sort
of minimalist look here, all
the way up to photo realistic
clouds and sunshine.
In fact, not just sunshine, but
an actual from space photo
of the sun, which looks a
little bit frightening.
RETO MEIER: That's
kind of nice.
And they've even got the rich
notifications here as well,
which do in fact show you the
current temperature up on the
status bar.
It's probably a little bit too
small to see, but it's there.
IAN NI-LEWIS: It is.
You can adjust what it shows,
but I love having the
temperature there because it
makes me feel like I'm in my
luxury automobile.
RETO MEIER: Nice.
So we should move on.
We've spent a lot of time on the
first app already, so we
are running out of time, but
we'll just make a quick note
of the fact that they have this
ability to upgrade to pro
to remove ads and support
development on the bottom.
It's actually quite
a nice treatment.
It follows with the general
design aesthetic here, so it
doesn't feel too aggressive.
And if we follow that through,
goes to Google Play to allow
to buy a key.
So they've used a key
approach here.
One alternative, which might be
a little bit less intrusive
for users, is to use in-app
billing to do an
upgrade that way.
IAN NI-LEWIS: I really prefer
that, and I'll tell why,
because the in-app billing will
follow the user's account.
You don't have to
have two apps.
The one thing that's nice about
having a pro version and
a free version is that the free
version can ask for the
permissions necessary for ad
networks, and you don't have
to add that to the
pro version.
But I feel like the key
policy here is the
worst of both worlds.
The original app has to ask
for all of the permissions
that the free version needs,
and yet it isn't as easy to
purchase as in-app purchase
would be.
RETO MEIER: So that may be
something worth looking at.
We have in-app billing version
three now available, which
makes a lot simpler than
previous versions.
So it's definitely something
you want to investigate to
help your monetization
efforts.
The last app we want to look
at, we want to give Ian a
chance to give us some
more deep dive
information on that map view.
But before we do, possibly one
of my favorite apps from
today, Should I Wear
Pants Today?
IAN NI-LEWIS: See, and I looked
at this and I thought,
wow, this has to be
a British app.
And then I remember that no,
in Britain pants mean
something different.
But what are Australia?
RETO MEIER: That would be
a very different app.
IAN NI-LEWIS: I know
you call football
soccer and soccer football.
RETO MEIER: No, we use
the American pants.
IAN NI-LEWIS: You say soccer?
RETO MEIER: Yeah, well--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
IAN NI-LEWIS: So pants and
soccer are same in Australia
as they are in America.
RETO MEIER: Exactly.
It's like in both countries--
well in all countries, it's
inappropriate to play soccer
in just your pants,
but nonetheless.
We have a look at the feature
graphic, it's
actually pretty nice.
I'm not sure that it quite
works as an icon.
It gets a little bit
too crowded.
You want to take that same idea
and perhaps stylize it a
little, so that you've got a
pair of pants, or trousers as
they like to say in the UK,
with a question mark.
But actually having that photo
realistic image of the cutoff
cargos doesn't work quite so
well when get down to it.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Photo realism
doesn't really work on icons.
RETO MEIER: Exactly.
It works great on the feature
graphic, but maybe you want to
reconsider.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Adobe Illustrator
can vectorize that
for you in a heartbeat.
RETO MEIER: Boom, very nice.
I do like the fact that they
haven't stuck it on a square
rounded background.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Thank
god for that.
RETO MEIER: Thank
you for that.
Let's switch to the
giant phone and
we'll fire up the app.
And again, they've actually
got a really nice, really
straightforward UI, which just
looks up what the current
temperature is, and suggests
what you should wear.
IAN NI-LEWIS: And it looks like
today, Reto, you will be
wearing a blouse and a
pair of hot pants.
RETO MEIER: That's right.
So a Friday?
IAN NI-LEWIS: Yep.
RETO MEIER: You're able to
scroll through here and see
what you want to wear
today, tomorrow.
Now we are in northern
California, so it is basically
going to be the exact same
thing between now and I'm
going to say April
of next year?
It's hard to say.
But it's actually really nice.
It still does give you the
temperature in your current
location at the bottom so that
you can confirm whether or not
this is stuff that you want.
IAN NI-LEWIS: And it
does have the very
important flip-flop report.
RETO MEIER: Yes.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Can you wear
flip-flops today?
Did it rain last night?
RETO MEIER: This is what
people are asking.
Now most of the magic actually
happens within the
preferences.
Now the good news here is that
it does default to things
which are reasonably sensible.
So you start up the app straight
away, and you get
what it does.
You either find it amusing and
kind of cool, or you're like,
yeah, maybe not.
But here you get to go through
and really add all of this
customization.
So you can basically set at what
temperature your cut off
is to be able to wear
cut-offs, and
so on and so forth.
You can select your gender,
you can select your
temperature units, you can
choose to add a little bit of
swagger to your look--
sunglasses at night, if
that's your thing--
and all of this sort
of stuff and this
goes through to modify--
IAN NI-LEWIS: It's really '80s
pop song day today, isn't it?
RETO MEIER: It kind of is.
We're showing our age,
but nonetheless.
So we really like this, I think
this is really clever.
This is one of those apps which
I think of as being a
little bit magic, in that it
does something which brings a
smile to your face.
It elicits that response
where you're like, OK,
that's kind of cool.
IAN NI-LEWIS: And really my
only quibble is that the
overall skin is so dark that
I thought it was disabled.
And then I realized it's not
disable, it just apparently
was drawn by the same guy that
does The Series of Unfortunate
Events books.
RETO MEIER: So yeah, you may
want to bump up your contrast
just a little, add a little bit
more color, just so you
can see what's going on.
But these are real nitpicks.
This is a really clever little
app that's really imaginative.
So nicely done.
IAN NI-LEWIS: It could
be a widget.
RETO MEIER: It could be
a widget, that's true.
It would actually be
really good widget.
I like that.
So with that in mind, we've
got a few minutes left.
Ian has some tips for drawing
things in GL.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Yeah, well, I was
intrigued by it Weather
Bomb's map, and I thought wow,
not only is it pretty, but
it's also kind of fast.
And so I decided to look
into it a little
more with GL Traceview.
And I found some interesting
things.
I know we don't have a ton of
time, but I'm just going to
look a little bit over what
Weather Bomb does.
Of course, this is Reto's
time to move.
There.
OK, there all right.
We try and we try.
Now, when you open up GL
Traceview on this app, the
first thing you're going to see
is this frame over here
that's actually everything
but the map.
And the reason is that the frame
is being drawn in a GL
surface view.
The way this works is there is a
windowing system in Android,
just like there is in any other
modern operating system.
You don't really use it very
often because everything's
done with activities.
But in this case, what we have
is a view here that's going to
actually get a hole
punched it.
In other words, part of it's
going to be transparent and
there's going to be a window
underneath it, which is
actually showing the map.
Now this area here is being
drawn in a second context.
It's important to set your
context right up here.
There we go, a little
button there.
And so that's context one,
and let's see how
the draw the map.
So the first draw call just
draws the map, and you see
it's about six triangles.
I don't even know why it's
six, it could be two.
Next thing that's going to get
drawn is the actual overlay.
This is what made
me intrigued.
Because if you look at some
of these, you can see that
there's some interesting
artifacts that are basically
coming out of the process
of coloring this.
And if you've worked much with
GL, you probably know exactly
what's going on already.
What's going on is the author
has overlaid a fine mesh over
the top of this texture that
contains the map, and then
used vertex coloring on each
piece of that mesh.
Each vertex is actually using
a look up to find-- now,
vertex coloring actually
is slightly wrong.
We're doing a per vertex text
chord into this essentially
one-dimensional texture that
takes us all away from the
deep purple up to
the bright red.
And that's our color code for
whatever it is we're looking
at, in this case, rainfall.
So that's going to be the next
step, is drawing that overlay.
Immediately, this sort of set
off alarm bells my head,
because I thought, well, you've
just overwritten a huge
number of pixels.
Because all of this area--
and this is especially important
when you're looking
at some of the other rainfalls
in areas of the world where it
rains more-- all of these areas
are actually not being
blended at all.
They're simply replacing
pixels that were there.
But that's not a huge deal.
And in fact, it's not anywhere
close to being the most
expensive thing that
this view does.
But if you want to save a few
cycles on your GPU, you may
want to remember draw
front to back.
Now you'll have one objection
if you're the
author of this program.
You'll probably tell me that
I can't draw front to back
because I'm blending,
and that is true.
That does introduce
some issues.
But you could actually eliminate
a lot of overdraw by
perhaps stenciling out the areas
that have rainfall or
have data on them.
But as I said, a really
minor point.
And the only reason I really
bring it up is because there's
a lot of apps that have
significantly more overdraw
than this, and still draw
everything back to front, And
that's a real problem.
want to draw front to back so
that you can take advantage of
z rejection.
Now, here's step three.
It's a little hard to see what
they've done here, but step
three is actually drawing the
tiny little dot that tells me
where I am, and step four
puts a little white
square inside that dot.
I don't know if you can
see that or not.
So anyway, not a big deal.
Where is the performance
loss coming from?
Oh, I'm sorry, did I say
performance loss?
I also said that this map
draws really fast.
Yes it does, but how long
does it take to draw?
17 milliseconds.
That's good enough to mostly
keep us at 60 FPS on a very
fast device, which is what
I tested this on--
it was a Nexus 7.
On a slower device, or one
that doesn't have as much
memory bandwidth, or one that
just has different performance
characteristics, you're going
to run a lot slower.
17 milliseconds is really
on the edge.
It's actually just a little less
than 60 FPS, but that's
the highest frame
time that I saw.
So, what is eating
up all the time?
Well it's not actually
the GPU.
Now, you don't see it in this
view, because you have to run
Systrace to see it, but the GPU
overhead on this is just
three to four milliseconds,
which isn't bad for something
that's drawing this
many pixels.
No, what's really eating
up all the time
is this over here.
One draw call, 17
milliseconds.
That's just one call, and it's
not even the one that touches
the most pixels.
This is the call to
draw the overlay.
So what is it doing wrong?
Well, the real problem is that
it's not just drawing these
vertices, it's also memcopying
them, and that's really where
things get heavy.
There's actually two arrays here
that are being set up.
And then they are being
drawn using this DL
draw elements call.
One of them is apparently, if
you look at the contents,
probably the weather
information itself.
A bunch of integers, they kind
of cluster in odd ways.
That's probably our weather
information.
That's going to vary
per frame.
Maybe not enough to
justify redoing it
every frame, but yeah.
But the next one, which is even
larger, is a bunch of
floats that are probably never
going to vary, because these
are all the vertices that
go into this mesh.
And there's no real reason
to change those ever.
Even if you're zooming the map
in and out, you can just
change the projection
on those.
So why are we sending
them every frame?
There's no reason.
Those should go in a vertex
buffer object.
So, I think we'll go ahead
and sum up now.
There's nothing wrong with this
app, but it's skirting
the edge of going from buttery
to janky, and with just a few
very, very slight changes,
it could be far
into buttery territory.
All right, let's go ahead and
take a closer look at today's
apps to talk about next steps.
RETO MEIER: That's right, so
we're going to see how close
they all are to be pure Android,
and to do that, we're
going to pass them through
each of these checklists.
So we can already see that
there's a little bit of work
needs to be done on
a few these apps.
We haven't had a chance yet to
look at them on tablets.
I'm hoping there's a great
tablet experience,
particularly for Weather Bomb,
which looks like it could be
really great immersive sort of
weather exploration tool.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Oh yeah.
RETO MEIER: So we're going to go
through and have a look at
how each of those things go.
And I am going to use my mind
to change the slide.
Until then, you can find our
pure Android collection at
bit.ly/PureAndroid, and you
can nominate your apps for
consideration by adding
it to our Trello page.
You can find that by searching
for App Clinic Trello.
We're going to be back next week
looking at kid mode apps,
which I think is a topic
of particular
interest for yourself.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Indeed, I will
be showing lots of cute
pictures of my baby daughter.
But, tune in anyway, because
we'll also be covering apps
and some interesting things
that you need keep in mind
when you're developing apps for
children, especially kid
mode lock screens.
RETO MEIER: Absolutely.
So tune in for that, and also
tune in next Tuesday for
Android Design in Action.
IAN NI-LEWIS: And until
next week, we are
the eye in the sky--
RETO MEIER: --looking at you--
IAN NI-LEWIS: --and we
can read your mind.
RETO MEIER: See you
all next week.